in five four three two one
what's up you stupid smelly [ __ ] the
heat going back I don't know why special
guest today you were actually in my bag
of people that I wanted to bring on this
podcast first nice but I have this list
of people that I know that it'll be
great on this podcast that I say for a
lot of time just because I need to get
all the bad people everybody who used to
be on it not that bad feels more like I
don't know if they'll be great on the
podcast base because it requires people
to really speak their mind right and I
think like when you when you do podcast
you have to be that person that that
draws those stories out because a couple
of people that are on here they're not
they're not even in this type of space
at all mmm so for me I'm like okay well
it's it's more on my my ability to to
get them to talk yeah right so for you
you have like Ricky's easy so I'm gonna
ask you to not get me in trouble cuz we
both talking a lot of [ __ ] people just
got to go to your Twitter I don't know
whatever you get offended by my Twitter
you're supposed to be offended do when
you tweet some [ __ ] I might I agree with
that but I can treat it you know what
the funny thing is like there's this
like thing about you what people people
like Ricky hates black people dude
there's literally no reason other than
the fact that they've seen a bunch of
different race women in my videos like I
haven't I haven't heard that in a long
time but that was basically it
but I've heard that like since high
school from black girls that I would try
to talk to you that weren't interested
in me then I go and talk to like a
Mexican girl and they're like I don't
really I tried to talk to you you don't
like me
but now I love black women well that's
kind of interesting cuz like I am I
remember that was like training around
where people would always associate you
with not liking playing you know what I
think it is
it's because I think some of the loudest
opinion most opinionated women and like
they're very strong it's it's that on
Twitter and it happens to be black girls
like 50% of them yeah and so for you
when you see a lot of stupid [ __ ] that
you read you got the clap back you know
I think a lot of the times there's a lot
of um like Twitter's culture right now
is a lot of like many and [ __ ] type of
stuff yeah alright and like Twitter it's
like popping you know and I can I keep
reading it over and over and over and
there's a lot of attributes that that's
not very gender related right yeah it's
like oh [ __ ] man chief [ __ ] Benji
wouldn't you do what they're talking
about
that's crazy my next video is titled
women cheat to talk about exactly what
we're talking about right now that's
that's the weirdest thing because when
I'm on Twitter and I understand you know
people get hyped you know it's it's it's
a lot of their own personal feelings
about they went through so it just
becomes magnified when you see somebody
type something that it resonates with
yeah but for me when I read that stuff
it's more like you kind of putting [ __ ]
out there that makes guys seem really
bad I'm like what kind of men do you
hang around with yeah exactly
and I mean like there's this really
shitty people out there there's a bunch
of [ __ ] men like we'd all know some
shitty ass men there's a bunch of shitty
as women too and I think both sides got
it [ __ ] up
yeah because there's men who think just
women as a whole are the devil yeah
because of their personal experiences
and then there's women who think the
same [ __ ] about men and just like a so
something's wrong with what you're doing
because there's people out there who are
not like that
yeah you're attracting these kind of
people into your life and somebody wants
to believe that it's like that same
concept where I would talk about
especially I would hear this a lot where
people are like well I don't understand
why I have so many toxic people in my
life but I'm like maybe as you maybe is
you you have no friends like maybe it's
probably you at this point out of the 30
years you've been living and you always
don't have friends yeah I guarantee it's
probably yeah not definitely and you you
can see it from the outside you know you
you're the problem
yeah it's you out I wouldn't hang out
with you
what you say do you watch yourself yo
yeah when a Tim and I did this awesome
foods there was this drug talked about
it on Tom's podcast but we had this
whole issue where I made this joke is
this loose women joke I'm pretty sure
Tim told you about it but in the
beginning of said foods mm-hmm
the ongoing joke on stem foods is that
Tim is famous and I'm not right which is
a joke but it's slightly true you know
stings a little but you know so every
time we do this stuff and you know girls
come up to and talk to him the ongoing
joke on the show is that women like come
and I don't so I say whatever it it's
not there's no foundation in it right so
I'm just trying to be as offensive as
possible because I'm salty the joke is
I'm salty yeah so it doesn't matter who
it is it could be an old lady it could
be a little kid I'm like [ __ ] that
ugly-ass little kid [ __ ] that old lady's
kneecaps yeah it doesn't matter so when
we were on the thing this is to regular
looking girls very pretty oh my God look
at these loose women you know only lose
women come up to Tim and one of them got
there like well huh and I normally don't
respond in that type of fashion and
usually when I do respond back it's
usually funny but I got really upset and
this this Instagram post got taken down
because it got flagged by her and all of
her bitch-ass friends because she wrote
she goes women are you gonna support
this type of man that calls women loose
and [ __ ] like I can't believe that you
would degrade that are our gender that
way I mean it I wasn't degrading
anybody's gender if anything I was just
degrading you as an individual you know
which which you weren't a part of that
joke so it's understandable the thing
that pissed me off was like she was
trying to catch me on something to make
me look bad as a whole yeah China trying
to cancel culture you exactly that's
exactly what it was and I was like hold
on a second you don't even understand
the context of the joke yeah the joke it
has nothing to do with you I'm actually
making fun of myself yeah exactly you
know but you know I I had to do this
whole thing where I thought to my mom
about it because I talked to her a lot
about this personal [ __ ] and I was like
okay what the [ __ ] should I do with this
right you know she's like she's like a
woman I'm very close to it she goes
honestly she goes if she feels offended
by this then you should apologize
because she didn't know
she was a part of this joke yeah other
angry mom yeah okay I got it
right so I apologize - I was like hey I
talked to my mom blah blah and this is
what she says and I agree with her so if
you felt offended by this because you
weren't a part of this joke that I
didn't let you in yeah and then people
said and you know people were calling
her a [ __ ] and everything else and I
see that means other people didn't get
the joke either yeah so that's what were
they were adding to the joke oh yes but
still cheating exactly so I was like
well it doesn't change the fact that you
didn't laugh you got laughed at and you
weren't a part of it so I have to
apologize I just [ __ ] hated the
approach where she was trying to cancel
culture me awesome [ __ ] when she all she
could have said was yo that [ __ ] was
offensive and you didn't let me a part
of this joke and I want to say oh well
actually this is a bit that I do I
didn't mean anything by and it could be
over but instead she hit you with E yeah
this kind of guy he's that kind of yeah
yeah and I just said there's like this
loose woman yeah it's so [ __ ] funny
because when I should happen I was like
I got actually got heated not gonna
disappointed in myself because I was
like what the [ __ ] did I get so angry
about this [ __ ] makes me feel sometimes
like in these comments like it's dumb
because I'm getting caught up in some
[ __ ] with somebody who in my personal
opinion couldn't even compute without
cuz even after I explained myself she
still didn't get it she did even - even
right now she still doesn't get it
yeah like yeah yeah well she doesn't
want to get it yeah is it there's people
who want to be upset and want to make
you feel like there's no excuse there's
no excuse that you did and you have to
be sorry and repent forever and I'm
gonna make you feel bad forever it's
like nah that doesn't that doesn't work
on people like no I apologized
I meant it if you still want to be mad
be mad but on the flip side I get where
she's coming from though yeah because
that might not be the first time she
heard that [ __ ] you know I'm there yeah
she might have been accused of being
that before just because her shorts were
a little short or some [ __ ] like that
and that gets upsetting if I was a woman
and every time I felt like being cute
somebody was calling me a name I'd
probably be triggered by that [ __ ]
but everybody gotta learn to just listen
a little bit just just listen a little
bit let me explain yeah and I apologize
let go yeah I mean it was I think like
the part where I was like hmm
even after I apologized she was like I
forgot what it was but it was like a
very backhanded comment afterwards and I
just had a I was like you know what
she's probably hurt she's hurt she's
gonna say some salty s [ __ ] so just let
it go
it was something on the lines of like
you should learn how to be a better man
and I'm like oh you still don't you know
she you still don't understand the
context of the joke yeah I'm just cut
let it go being angry makes you popular
she's going for that who knows that's
the hot [ __ ] you know cuz I I feel like
I based my whole career off of being
angry yeah but at the end of the day
I'll still try to make people laugh yeah
I'm saying you know so it was supposed
to be jokes at the end of it because you
know when I was doing these vlogs when I
first started doing YouTube the point of
it was to crack jokes right I mean I
think that's just half the culture that
we grew up and we just crack jokes about
[ __ ] that bothered us I mean it helps
you cope with it or something yeah now
it's just there's no jokes now I'm like
where's the punchline people yeah yeah
yeah
but yeah I mean like for me I always
wanted to be funny but I'm never make it
joke I mean I mean all this [ __ ] I'm
saying but if you on the surface it
looks like that let's do that so you
always mad about that way you play so
much but I never pinpoint people young
one unless they reply to some fake [ __ ]
is it yeah then I'll go in on them and I
never just make a joke out of nowhere
yeah I'll say exactly how I feel with
some comedic elements to it yeah but
there's nothing to go back on so I never
have that I'm sorry moving cuz I don't
I'm not gonna tag nobody I'm not gonna
say well you're this and then have to
apologize for I'm gonna say what I feel
about the situation as a whole if you
get mad you get mad if you laugh you
laugh if you agree you agree and I just
leave it at that
have you ever had to take back a joke on
Twitter no no but that that's why I'm
strategic with it like um I very you're
very rarely gonna see me like Sam
[ __ ] you know how everybody's getting
canceled for old tweets I don't have to
go look to my old tweets for a lighter
Rachel slurs or homosexual slurs or
anything like that like I just never
done that one because I already knew
like that she's not gonna fly and - I
don't think it's funny I think there's
easier ways to be I mean not easy ways
there's better ways to be funny yeah the
racial jokes and like making fun of
people sexuality all that [ __ ] that's
easy
yeah as easy so I never took that route
but there is a lot of [ __ ] talking on
there that I stand behind almost
anything I said I probably stand behind
it to this day I feel like you're very
well thought out because when you go
sometimes I'm like what did whatever
Rick tweeted a anybody in a long time -
this dude the other day but it wasn't
really getting into it and the only
reason I went on him is because he was
on my girls [ __ ] talking [ __ ] about me
what exact well he was just making like
fat jokes and [ __ ] like that but like
super childish ones laughs when she told
me what was said I really thought I was
going like finding 8th grade kids and
[ __ ] like that I got there was wrong as
nails I cut the [ __ ] but I still wasn't
going hard at him I'll just say yo if
you you won't make jokes about me bring
it to my page yeah we watched some
harder why are you talking about you on
her page he was trying to flirt with her
I think I don't know I don't know I
don't want to put intentions in his head
but he's uh like asked her why she's not
fat why don't you get fat because she's
always eating [ __ ] oh that's that's him
trying to flirt in a [ __ ]
three-year-old way I guess and then she
trashed her I work out all the time with
some [ __ ] like that he was like oh I
guess that's why you're so fit and
beautiful or something like that man was
like does your boyfriend ever crush you
as a kid like yeah [ __ ] I was a
grown-ass man I'm like yo bro you gotta
come harder than that with the jokes and
bring them up it you know saying cuz
she's not there yet what she knows how
to just let [ __ ] go
she's always do on the space right yeah
you know his answer she's like trying to
finish it I'm like [ __ ] like our
fabulous forever that's why I don't do
it you'll die early and yeah
a terrible Fat Joe's like you gotta come
better than that so how do I tell them
to come better that better than that he
tries to hit me with the oh that's why
Tim made it and you did it I'm like dude
that's such a bad joke to suit one bad
joke after another yeah and it's like so
you're trying to be hurtful but saying
take a joke and you're not good at
either yeah like it's not a good joke
and it's not hurtful like I'm I will be
salty that my friend is doing well like
I don't get it so yeah but then we just
went back and forth for a little bit
basically just me telling him to come
bring it to my channel I mean my page
he's not going to not he and then he
ended with a semi funny joking I was a
seaman that's kind of funny in that was
um I was cuz the way I was saying come
to my page but it was kind of
threatening yeah but that's a stupid-ass
threat right yeah okay cool yeah just
make sure you don't jump me when I get
over here but it's like ah I see what
you did there that's kind of funny oh
that's not the funny way it was done
after that well that's just somebody who
just really wanted attention at that
point ya know that I think you was just
happy that you're talking to me to be
honest with you
probably that's why you edited with that
he's like ah [ __ ] Ricky shows talking me
yeah and like a loser I and I remember
that that's why I try not to get to man
when I'm going back cuz there's been so
many times where I I come hard yeah you
wanna talk [ __ ] yeah I do I'm a huge fan
I was just joking that's such a weird
thing that's so it but I get it I get
that too because a lot of us don't reply
unless is negative we go pass although
this is so funny and maybe like it or
some [ __ ] until somebody talk some [ __ ]
then you [ __ ] reply right away so the
kids are like okay well if I want to
talk to him that's such a weird thing
though like that that type of way of
hitting on a girl is the most childish
way I've ever seen in my life
yeah if I read that I just wrote cringe
period yeah but now I really thought it
was gonna be a kid it's not like a kid
yeah it sounds like a little kid yeah
that's so [ __ ] what the [ __ ] did you
think was gonna happen especially like
when I see these dudes they comment on
these instagrams but like you're so
[ __ ] beautiful I would give you the
whole world
what the [ __ ] did you think was gonna
happen you [ __ ] dweeb they thought
she was gonna say really like the whole
world what's you that's so [ __ ] weird
to me man like I definitely it's funny
because in 2019 I told myself you is a
year of positivity I'm really trying to
take what Tim does you know cuz you know
he's like a really happy go-lucky
so I'm like imma be a little Tim this
year right that's funny no pun intended
not gonna be a little Tim I try to take
a slice from this man's book mr+ yeah
and that [ __ ] has failed I failed on the
second day of the year how was I um
that's funny it's hard it's not in me
yeah like I'm like ah God you know what
I should I'm trying to be more
empathetic towards people I really don't
give a [ __ ] about yeah so it's like okay
well this person wrote this it's
probably just a kid but the part that
gets me is when it's not a kid yeah you
know it's like wait you should know
better you're like 30 or 40 years old
what are you doing yeah you you let me
tell you something about us versus Tim
and a lot of people are gonna disagree
with this but this is the truth we care
about people more oh we are more
compassionate in the temples of the
world so much so that we get mad people
are not living up I'm great oh yeah yeah
where we're like hey do better come on
yeah I'm serious like I think I get
aneurysms cuz I'm like don't don't say
anything they just just let this person
go and then I'm sitting on the toilet
taking a [ __ ] I have that it's to not
really to just like go off on somebody
but to teach it's just I don't know how
to do it in a nice way you know that but
it's just like [ __ ] how how do you not
see what's going on when I see these
grown-ass people in their mid-30s having
social media high school as problems
like yeah and I don't know how to say
what the [ __ ] are you doing in a nice
way yeah I tried it recently and it did
work out a little bit I forgot what it
was but we had a conversation with my
friend amen and she was talking about we
all his opening oh yeah I mean this
prophetic is [ __ ] like you should meet
her mom her mom is [ __ ] she floats on
air and just yeah so she um we were just
talking about like the usage of the
n-word we were talking about like
cultural appropriation you know all
these like hot topics yeah
but mm somebody I was trying to explain
to them why she would be so passionate
about people taking away from a culture
that feels like you know when she was
younger she used to give me fun of us
she talked about a personal story you
know people called her African booty
scratcher or whatever and there was a
parent who literally called her a [ __ ]
Yeah right and it made her cry you know
and so for her when she hears anybody
say [ __ ] it incites that feeling of
that moment yeah and so you know their
argument was well we're in 2019 you know
like blah blah that's like everybody's
arguments we're 2019 what's cultural
appropriation that doesn't exist we're a
melting pot and my thing was like you
can everybody says we're a melting pot
but people don't treat it like it is
yeah so you could say that but in this
country there is we want to feel that
way yeah but it's not there so that's
that's basically the point I was and I
said it nice and the person understood
yeah but there's another person who
didn't understand they just clap it back
at me and I was like aw see now I gotta
be mean yeah [ __ ] yeah that's a touchy a
subject because it's so much bigger and
smaller yeah we make it in it's like how
do you articulate that nobody gets it
because every culture wants to be
accepted they want to be loved but they
want it to a certain extent and seems
like like hey love and accept my culture
but not enough that you want to do it
too yeah that's a weird vibe like hey
except me doing it and love me doing it
and don't try to tell me anything is
wrong we do it but don't you [ __ ] do
what you ask and that that's weird to me
but then on the flip side you have
people that are like that's terrible
that's terrible that's terrible I'm
gonna do it a little bit though yes
like I feel like everybody's just kind
of [ __ ] up in that sense but whoever's
getting whatever side of that how do you
even talk to them about the other half
because you feel like the victim you're
always gonna feel like the victim and
you see exactly how it's negative to you
you don't give a [ __ ] about how it could
be positive somewhere else you just know
how it's negative to you and you want it
to change
so I've debated making that video and
having that conversation I'm like it's
gonna end with my people calling me a
sellout with other people being upset at
what I say they can't do it can't doing
[ __ ] like this I just kind of leave it
alone but it was such a weird thing cuz
I don't be repetitive but we just talked
about like how I think like when when we
were younger it was a lot more
acceptable it wasn't I think just
because Twitter and everything wasn't
there yeah and you know however people
felt about it at the time it just I
don't know why it wasn't that big of a
deal and I even talked about I remember
the first time there's this og they used
to kick it us out of my parents door
taught me how to use the word and he
would only let me call him by that name
he was a discolours he said when you see
me you say that I'm your [ __ ] now when
I was a little kid I didn't know what
that meant I just felt oh [ __ ] that's
that's cool yeah so I was just that kid
on the block because my parents own a
black beauty supply store yeah so they
were just letting me in the group you
know so the weird part is like I always
say is you know if you're not a part of
a culture where it doesn't affect you
right
then why do you need to say it is a
question that's not a question so on all
the [ __ ] I was saying I've about other
things when it comes to that word I
never understood the want to say it yeah
I get all the argument it's in music
it's this year here but it's like if you
know there are people who really don't
want you saying that [ __ ] ain't gonna
feel a real passionate way about it why
do you want to say it so bad I never
understood that
yeah the need was the weird part for me
is cuz when people say well I've heard
you say before I was like well I could I
grew up with it but I don't need to say
it doesn't it's not anywhere somebody
says don't say it I'm like well I have
to I'm like
are you probably right it's like move on
you know I'm like yeah I probably should
you know so that the argument of like
well it's just it's 2019 move on it's
like why do you need to like I
understand like the earth are you gonna
die if you don't
yeah and the freedom of speech I'm like
I guess we'll [ __ ] your mom too then
yeah exactly exactly and the Europe
anybody hey hey I could say what I want
you know then they're not gonna like
this that arguments the weird part for
me with their the freedom of speech
thing they're like so we're gonna censor
people on the things that we can and
can't say it's like that every day you
you can't tell me to go [ __ ] myself
without getting socked in the face yeah
so what exactly there's so many things I
can say to you that are gonna make you
feel like hey don't say that to me you
want me hey freedom of speech bro yeah
that's stupid
such a weird argument so it and I can't
I don't know how how I that's right so
how do you make a video about that how
do you explain that to somebody because
somebody's gonna clap back yeah it's too
many layers and it's too much to be
edited like even what I said here can be
taken and one chunk of it be said and it
is like oh you [ __ ] sellout you know
there's just like that yo that's so
[ __ ] true because when we had the
whole video it just came out this past
week where it came out and the original
video a lot of people [ __ ] with it but
if you just took a snippet out of it
people were just going in they hated it
they're like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about this world culture
appropriation doesn't exist but if you
heard the whole conversation and it'll
let up into that phrase it gets people
to understand where she's coming from
yeah right and so it's true like when
people will pick and choose what they
want to hear and it's a hot topic
they'll feel a certain way of minute
such a weird thing so it so cuz you grew
up in pair of paramount with Tim right
yeah so everybody was saying that [ __ ]
they um no they weren't so we had we had
a heavy like black versus brown [ __ ] for
most of my school it wasn't until like
my senior year that we stopped having an
annual race riot at the school that's
[ __ ] crazy yeah it was crazy so it
was like if you weren't well the the the
Hispanic kids didn't say they're like
the blacks Asians the Samoans yeah they
all said it you know I'm saying
I hear one group but yeah there was
division there was like nah you can't
say this yeah we could saying [ __ ] like
that you you when you when you started
doing why did you stop doing YouTube
like you on of just man I got tired of
it
it didn't make me happy anymore it
wasn't fun and I really didn't like the
people yeah like other youtubers yeah
and the lot of the viewers yeah I didn't
like them the [ __ ] they would say to me
saying well I'm not doing this for you
then you know yeah yeah yeah so not
being funny anymore
plus people in being [ __ ] I'm
[ __ ] boy the the the platform changed
a lot I think what I always say to when
I miss about it was back in the day
because there wasn't really money
involved people would just create just
to create yeah you know so there was a
lot of [ __ ] that was bad but there's a
lot of [ __ ] that would make me laugh
because everybody's channel was
different mmm-hmm everybody's channels
the same now so for me it's like why am
i watching this why am i watching this
why am i watching this I have literally
seen like this is the [ __ ] that gets me
all the time it's like when people
they're on camera right and they wake up
in the morning they deal when they wake
up in the morning what's up guys did you
don't [ __ ] talk like that when you
wake up put that [ __ ] camera down and
sometimes when we're outside mmm I like
what Tim does Tim goes blah warning so
people who don't want to be in it
they're allowed to be there they can
participate or not yeah I had to teach
him this okay from the beginning
people's earliest memories of me was me
shaking my head in
Tim vlogs because I'm cyber yeah you
want to show your life show your life
don't show my life yeah I don't want
them to know what I'm doing yeah it was
it was weird because like it got to a
point where you know there'd be like
group ships sometimes and people are
like oh let's go on trip and I'm like
I'm good you know what's gonna happen
like imma be there and then you're gonna
shove a camera in my face while I'm on
vacation
mmm and I ain't trying to have that yeah
and so you know when I would do these
trips like oh when you went to Hawaii
you had this whole crew but see
wasn't a vacation for me I said this is
work yeah and we worked but when I'm on
vacation vacation
unless I'm shooting from my [ __ ] that I
want to do yeah it's not gonna happen
you know and that's that's the weird
part to where I feel like people don't
understand that sometimes they're like
well why don't you want to be on it yeah
why would I exactly it it's work but
we're no weird-ass generation I guess
you would say because a lot of these
people don't know anything outside of it
because those lines are so blurred like
yeah when it's fun it's fun you don't
feel like you're working you're just
appetising on your time and you're
monetizing on your time cool but they
don't know how to turn it off
so there's been so many situations where
we're doing nothing that has to do with
YouTube but everybody's talking numbers
and how many subscribers do you have
yeah I'm trying to get my numbers
overall we should have a look and
there's no outside conversation other
than YouTube Instagram followers likes
all I shouldn't say you know this is
like your life your entire life is this
it's which sometimes like I've I've kind
of [ __ ] up because they have a very
family-friendly channel and sometimes
what I feel like I wanna be on it but
you know he doesn't do Tim the Tim blog
warning and you know Tim also too many
blogs you just be himself you know it's
like it's very natural to me like it
just feels like oh this is what we would
be talking about anyways doesn't matter
but I could swings the camera on me and
he just lightens up the energy which is
cool that's his thing yeah but I don't
want to be a part of this you know I
know he has a very family-friendly
channel so he just comes in he goes oh
what are you doing I'm not a [ __ ]
[ __ ] man you know [ __ ] ah
Recor be a tea boy just cuz my egos
can't use him he learned
yeah yeah and I if you're a vlogger and
you're watching this warn people before
you turn your camera on and turn into a
different person that's the weird part
is the transformation I'm not really
used to that so it's it's because I
remember I started vlogging cuz it was
like a new art thing
I did it for like it was a very short
period of time yeah and as I'm done with
this yeah and I got it moved on because
when I was on vacation I couldn't
remember anything that I did except for
what I saw through the camera mmm
I was like I [ __ ] wasted my vacation
what the [ __ ] did I do yeah
so we was the first time I ever did and
people liked it I was in Hawaii I had a
GoPro and I was making jokes the whole
time but if somebody asked me what I
remember from that trip the only thing I
can remember is recording and what I saw
to the screen yeah and that [ __ ] [ __ ]
depressed me I was like I wasted a [ __ ]
ton of money on nothing yeah exactly
what the [ __ ] did I do
so when I went to Taiwan I did I was
like super into like these travel
docu-series [ __ ] and I kind of went ham
on it but we had like a week and a half
there I only recorded for the first
three days yeah and then the other four
days I said nope left all the equipment
back and I just chilled out yeah do you
got to do that like I don't understand
and I know I sound old as [ __ ] I'm
saying this but like I hate Coachella
season hahaha because everybody's story
is a full [ __ ] concert I'm like how
are you enjoying it yeah like how you're
screaming for 10 seconds like you're
having the time of your life and then
you're putting your head down trying to
write a caption you're no longer paying
attention to what's going on there
you're trying to post it it's not going
through because there's no [ __ ]
service yeah I just I don't understand
that like live man live there's a time
for this [ __ ] and then there's a time to
just [ __ ] live I don't get it
that's why I really like I was thinking
about getting a 360 camera mmm cuz you
could just point it and leave it in the
captures everything yeah and then you
could do your own [ __ ] so if you want to
look back at it just go to the 36 cam
you just screen around like Oh should I
remember that yeah or you might see some
[ __ ] that you did see it look like these
[ __ ] are [ __ ] in the corner
no I'm not it's weird when Coachella was
really popping off and it still is
obviously but I've never really liked
big crowds of people hmm
and I think because I feel like we're in
entertainment people feel like that's
that's the vibe that we're on yeah they
go oh you can be a Coachella I'm not a
Coachella person yeah yeah I'm not I'm a
very irritable human being when I'm in a
situation where there's a bunch of
people touch me that I
No yeah you know so it's why I never
like going to clubs even though I only
did it when I was younger just because
there was women there yeah and my
friends did it you know so I'm like more
of a bar scene type of dude but even
that I don't even drink as much as I
used to and so well I drink on Sam food
okay but other than that are you going
to this fridge no alcohol no yeah
because I [ __ ] my house like it's about
me like I do that I think it's for me
it's a cultural thing because I grew up
you know Korean people drink like a
[ __ ]
so even in Korea like our favorite drink
is soju soju cheaper than water in Korea
yeah it's it's like that it's like it's
like it's like a dollar for a bottle of
soju it's like two bucks for a dump a
lot of water yeah it's like that that's
how much like drinking and smoking is a
part of that culture so for me like for
celebration reasons I drink and have fun
depending on the people Yeah right so if
it's like some random people that I
don't really [ __ ] with and let's drink I
might drink would you
yeah I'm not gonna have fun you know
Tim's a very fun person so I'm like
let's drink
yeah you're my drinking buddy um yeah
I'm kinda the same like I don't like
crowds the first time with the Coachella
I didn't know what the [ __ ] I was
getting into
yeah and me and uh Andrew Garcia we
ended up getting like in the back of the
crowds and just watching the shows from
the big screens towards the end of it
like yo I'm not going back in there like
that shit's crazy and then I probably
been two times since and I just had to
mentally prepare myself yeah and still
end up in the back or like do the VIP
[ __ ] you know the one time I wish I went
to Coachella though went pop College
[ __ ] go home I didn't know about that
[ __ ] nobody knew it was a total surprise
and I was pissed
that's why that's the only reason we
went the next year because I know that's
the type of [ __ ] they do okay so we went
I just tweeted that last night oh okay
and then yeah apparently there's a
hologram theater in Hollywood some shoot
that works there cuz I was like I always
regret missing this moment you say well
next time you're in Hollywood come to
the hologram theater and watch me here
and it's like
[ __ ] Holograms oh [ __ ] that [ __ ] was
wild man yeah when I first saw it I got
I got the chills and shells like you
know what because there was nothing like
that before and it looked so real you
know what's interesting when uh there's
this huge conversation going on because
when nipsey passed yeah you know what's
funny when nips are not funny but when
you mentioned nipsey careful my words it
was hilarious when he died oh you hit me
up you're like yo you want to be in a
[ __ ] nipsey video like oh [ __ ] oh yeah
yeah oh [ __ ] you know I I know of nipsey
yeah only from his like earlier mixtapes
but he was dope cuz he's like a West
Coast rapper yeah so I was surprised
when he passed away a lot of my friends
were like yeah [ __ ] with nipsey I was
like really like he's such a West Coast
dude like I never thought a lot of
people listened to him outside of like
people in California yeah because the
guy is he's a [ __ ] great yeah yeah
super intelligent like yeah me I got
into this thing a few years back where I
was like I'm not gonna waste my time
listening the new rappers anymore when
all the littles came out and the mumble
Redmond [ __ ] so so I heard the name but
I didn't give him a chance I didn't give
him a chance I didn't give j-roc a
chance I didn't give Tom Kennedy and I
didn't listen to [ __ ] right but then I
would catch his interviews on like The
Breakfast Club or something like that I
was like oh I like this dude I became a
fan of him speaking more than the music
yeah like I still only listen to a
select few like before he passed yeah
just because of his interviews yeah that
brought me to the music but I [ __ ]
with him heavy just based off what he
said I mentioned this too on a video
where I was talking about how I actually
started liking him because I friend of
mine he doesn't music and he told me
that nipsey used to do this thing where
he wanted to curate music fans and so he
would sell his mixtape wares albums for
$100 yeah you know so if you really want
to [ __ ] with me this is how you're gonna
do it because I put
amount of time into this artwork and
this is what it's worth yeah and I
[ __ ] I was a damn that's [ __ ] crazy
and I did well that day well jay-z by
like tangos mixtapes that's [ __ ]
crazy
that's one time I went to when Dipsy
passed away no just bring it back to the
pot people were talking about oh there
was like this POC versus nipsey yeah
what was that about I was like what the
[ __ ] is because everybody was drawing
the parallels you know I'm saying like
Park said a lot of similar [ __ ] - what
nipsey was actually doing and that's
where the comparison comes in because
people were liking him in the park even
he said it pocket his generation in a
song you know I'm saying and then people
who were just really hurt by the passing
would be like awesome Tupac wish type
[ __ ] if she actually did what he was
talking about but it's like pop got
gunned down before he could do all the
things he wanted to do and if she had a
little bit more time yeah and he got the
blueprint from POC he puts it into uh he
actually did the work you know I'm
saying both of them were dope I hate the
fact that they're doing this who was
better comparison time [ __ ] that's so
[ __ ] like they were both dope but if
see he was the pocket his generation did
you listen to a bigger pot a lot when
you were younger
both I listen to be later I think it was
because I was so young and the people
are like where's girls cuz I'm like [ __ ]
me and I was like damn big [ __ ] bad
for like I liked I was a big West Coast
man you know I'm saying because the East
Coast do everything was just a little
slower everything seemed gloomy or a
[ __ ] I like this fun
these synths over here yeah [ __ ] but
big-hat huff and puff was digging in the
crates for his production yeah he was
sampling everything so the sound drew me
I was like okay I can listen from New
York so make him dmx
you know I'm saying I really [ __ ] with
so I got to see early on that big was
dope and he had bars his flow was
impeccable but pop was bad
storyteller I'll say that to the end of
time so I probably [ __ ] with pop more
but I definitely listened to a lot of
big I don't think people would argue
that stuff that Park was a better story
just had that argument today
well one of my dumbass friends right
here thinks big was a better storyteller
than pocket he actually said pop was
trash he lucky I don't put him on blast
let everybody know who he is
he said I was trash how in what context
just overall he was like I try I was
listening to Liz it don't make no sense
I was like damn you like for real stupid
you have to be stupid if you can listen
to a song and think it makes no sense
you didn't understand what he was saying
you're dumb who's your favorite [ __ ]
little Zab [ __ ] yeah how [ __ ] miss
Martha
blasphemous [ __ ] you know I'm
not even like when I go back to listen
to POC sounds like well obviously for me
there's a lot of nostalgia oh yeah
nobody looked at POC saying that he was
an amazing lyricist he was a great
storyteller knit and he was very good at
relaying emotions yeah like a poet you
know and so that's what I loved about
his [ __ ] like even when I die there's
two pockets that need to play that's the
type of you know how many brothers
failed me like I'm not even a thug I
didn't even die from a like a bullet
wound you know that's playing at my
[ __ ] funeral
exactly something about his music made
me feel a certain way and with it with
Biggie when I listened to it later on
when I was like 13 or 14 it was more
like oh [ __ ] this fool knows how to ride
a beat and he just has like he'd the way
he weaves his words was [ __ ] wild to
me ya know big biggie was there bars his
flow was crazy he was very clever yeah
but yeah pop parks reach was just bigger
to me because he can make one record
that so many people feel on so many
levels
yeah big he could bring me into his
world I get it you know that but I don't
feel anything from it this I don't draw
any parallels from it I've had a way of
making everybody
being able to say something that almost
anybody can relate to in the song and I
thought that [ __ ] was dope I think this
generation has they got Jake : Kendrick
that seems to be their POC and their
biggie yeah or something like that yeah
okay yeah yeah or maybe to to pop I
don't know who would be the equivalent
to big event that's very hard to say you
don't want to say cuz people will get
mad but just in terms of ability to make
really good songs
you can't leave Drake out but he's
nothing like there's no other big
Ecology's it's a Jake but it took me a
lot of lights right it took me a while
like I don't I don't know what it was
about him that I [ __ ] hated but maybe
it was his [ __ ] face I don't know
what it probably had nothing to do with
this music because I couldn't deny that
I'll be walking around and I would just
start humming at Drake song I'm like you
[ __ ] intercepted my mind you stupid
son of a [ __ ] but then you know he just
started I was like goddamn he's a
musician's musician do ya like I can't
deny his music because it's it's good
yeah you know it's really good I think I
just started feeling weird you know what
it was now I'm starting to remember it's
cuz this [ __ ] will put on 17
different basketball jerseys you just
get [ __ ] team hoppy yeah and I was
like [ __ ] this guy this guy doesn't know
what the [ __ ] he's doing here eyes
chance but he does it well he does it
well and but that [ __ ] MIG Jordan did
you see that you know I got my eyes on
you and it was all off-key for like
three minutes straight yeah both of them
it was so bad I was in tears laughing
that's funny
cuz you know those two they you know
they well they tune their voice a lot
which sounds dope yeah but I guess like
on Ellis show they don't really allow
you to do much with that [ __ ] you have
to do it live love yeah and they got it
[ __ ] up and that's what I'm finding
out a lot of these artists have to sing
live and they're like oh that's what
they're never gonna be on NPR tiny desk
yeah exactly
they're no t-pain he did know that was
the biggest shock on earth to me I had
no [ __ ] idea
yeah I get when he he tweeted not too
long ago that uh buy you a drink I do
believe yeah he's like that's always
like 98 percent on auto tune but people
just hear it in Auto Tunes I had to go
back and listen I was like holy [ __ ] oh
this is nothing
and like only the hook part is auto tune
oh [ __ ] yeah but because it was t-pain
that's how I heard it in my head I heard
it all the tunes is [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
that's this crazy way he sees his tiny
desk concert was the [ __ ] yeah that [ __ ]
blew my mind and then I felt super big
oh we lost a lot of people this year
[ __ ] yeah cuz I didn't even uh I went
back to his tiny desk concert he's like
I forgot how dope this [ __ ] kid
wasn't because I didn't like a couple of
his albums but his last one that came
out was pretty dope but I ignored it
because it had the most previous ending
really [ __ ] with it and I was like ah
[ __ ]
I felt I felt I don't know I felt so bad
when he passed I was like man I should
have just went back a little bit and
listen to his stuff cuz I went back that
tiny desk concert I was like that's
[ __ ] Mac Miller right there yeah
made me sad it was a sad [ __ ] like but
again I didn't really listen cuz I got
had my thing where I'm just like you
know what [ __ ] it I'm putting on G Depp
but yes I didn't really listen I didn't
know did you listen to uh are you listen
to a lot of new artists now no I'm still
not like I lost my my urge I lost my
love for music yeah so now I'm like [ __ ]
I'm just behind I'm the old dude they're
[ __ ] that's how it is for me too
like you know when um when I listen to
music I feel like it's getting really
repetitive to me now yeah so there's
only a few artists that are coming out
that I really really really enjoy but
you know I got a way for that person
specifically to make an album yeah like
I'm waiting for a Kendra to drop another
one J Cole but outside of that yeah well
who am I looking for you know people
will drop different names and stuff and
I think those those are dope emcees but
they don't just resonate with me as well
yeah I don't know what it is I think is
is everything's oversaturated like I'm
I'm more willing to listen to singers
new album than a new
you know I'm saying like who just put a
Anderson Peck
whoo mentor - is hard you know I'm
saying and I read that review that heist
'nobody did I didn't I said it was trash
what said it was boring that it was one
note that it was not as anywhere as good
as Oxnard and everything and it was
trashing his whole album and ster I
don't know who that writer was but broke
they weren't talking some mad [ __ ] about
[ __ ] Ventura and I was like dude
Ventura was [ __ ] amazing
venters better than Oxnard to me that's
what I thought - yeah maybe they just
wanted more hip-hop wrapped up [ __ ] you
know I'm saying but like we we've known
him him before he was at Jack you know
that we knew the voice we knew the soul
we knew all that [ __ ] easy love joy man
yeah exactly so maybe I don't know I
don't know that's that's interesting but
I think it's dope he [ __ ] Smokey
Robinson that's me you got Lala Hathaway
jazmine sullivan on there Andy I think
you thinking Brandi sounds like jasmine
but people don't even know how dope
brandi is dude Joo
she's so dope you know what you know the
reason why I like Tori Kelly so much is
because Tori Kelly does similar runs
that Brandi does yeah so I'm not ever
really got to speak to Tori Kelly but
I'd be surprised if she didn't listen to
a lot of Brandi yeah I would lose press
it like a lot of these new girls
I hear Brandi in there yeah like oh
there's been a lot of times cuz I my
chick misses a new music all the time
yeah so in a car I'll let her play the
[ __ ] and I'm like oh like Teyana Taylor
I love to unit and she got a lot of
joints that sound like Brandi inspired
yes yes but yeah I'm more into singers
than
some of these singers are [ __ ] amazed
me like I always wondered you know how
did you feel about when Bruno Mars was
getting a loan I got [ __ ] do every
album of Bruno Mars I just get to repeat
repeat his last album I say to me it's
kind of weird for me to say this just
because it's something that it's a
recent album yeah so I've never I've
never spun a record so much in my
[ __ ] life like his album yeah from
beginning to [ __ ] end yeah it's very
rare I listen to an album from beginning
then I go play that whole [ __ ] back yeah
it was [ __ ] wild to me I'm like how
did he [ __ ] get everything that I
like about the music I used to like and
everything that I like now and the one
[ __ ] alone he's amazing bro like out of
his three albums there's only one song
that I skip and that's the [ __ ] you
can count on me like 1 2 3 oh yeah yeah
that's the only song you know there
other than that I could listen to a
[ __ ] Bruno Mars playlist oh I feel
like when I get married you just got to
play that whole album pretty much yeah
we're good and everybody good
it's so [ __ ] good yeah it was a kind
of a weird weird I forgot what I was
watching on YouTube but it was who the
[ __ ] was it but it I'm not sure it was
like a group of just all I'm not sure
how prominent they are in the music
industry or if it's just like very well
spoken black people but they were
talking about the issue of Bruno Mars
and how it was just goes back to that
culture appropriation yeah like uh there
was half the site that really [ __ ] with
Bruno Mars and the other one that they
were just trashing him saying that
talking about his album they're like
well his album was probably was was
amazing and the other half was saying it
wasn't because he's stealing from black
culture yeah and I guess like I didn't
know that was an issue when number one I
actually thought Bruno Mars was black so
yeah I thought so too for a minute but
yeah he's like Puerto Rican a Hawaiian
yeah I had no clue but there was this
big topic about like well for [ __ ] him
because he's taking for all of our [ __ ]
and taking all credit so now and what
the music's great now because we have
this Puerto Rican Hawaiian do singing it
now and I never really thought about
that because I always thought that he
did his due diligence
and paying respect Amish that that's how
I see it and I feel like I feel like
people like to be mad mmm I understand
because there has been so many people
who have done it just still and
appropriate and mimicked and don't
really know it but Bruno you can tell he
grew up on that [ __ ] yeah you can tell
he's authentic and let's not talk about
the music he wrote for black artists
yeah yeah or he was poppin you know I'm
there like it's it's what comes natural
to him it's always been there and I saw
a little bit of that and it bothered me
because if you really listen to the
album he's not only taking from black
music yeah he has a [ __ ] Bee Gees type
ballot on there yeah you know what I'm
saying like he's just taking from time
not necessarily a genre it's all
different types it there's New Jack
Swing there's ya R&B there's old pop
younam's and all of that on that album
but people hear the single and the [ __ ]
with cardi B you know and they make that
what his whole album was about and yes
that kind of bugged me there was there
was a you know with the whole [ __ ]
Old Town Road oh yeah you see that this
is a [ __ ] about that where there was
like you know it was it was whatever
well Tim kind of like broken down to me
where it was on a [ __ ] and they took it
down so Billy Ray Cyrus came on he goes
[ __ ] that that's that's a dope country
song yeah and it went back up on the
charts and there was a thing going on
about it about the ownership of what
country music is yeah they're like
that's actually black music and so you
can't tell us not that doesn't add up
yeah and I hear about that yeah there
was there was a thing about that [ __ ]
and I was like well hold on a second the
reason why I felt I understand just
because I feel like when when people go
back yeah [ __ ] just African people
had a bunch of instruments so they their
influences was everywhere yeah blues
jazz whatever everybody's taking from
that at a certain point and
the reason why I felt a little weird
about that where I feel like sometimes
people reach really hard is because what
I remember as a kid if you were a black
dude Asian dude whatever and you were
listening to country music they would
say while you listen that white boy
music yeah so why is it now where it's
like that's our music yeah well the
reason for that yeah is because
billboard tried to exclude him mm gotcha
because for a while nobody knew that kid
was black
like that song was just popping on
tick-tock uh-huh and we just thought it
was this hip hop and sounding country
song and and people thought it was funny
because of that yeah not like not like
Soulja Boy funny but just go [ __ ] they
fused to hip hop in country and it's
country dudes kind of cool my cousin was
and they found out is a black kid he's
like oh [ __ ] Oh reasons the reason it
even got to the Billboard charts I
believe is because of tick tock because
everybody was using that to make the
same little skit yes back to what we
were saying earlier everybody just
copies everything yeah yeah so that's
kind of how it charted and it seemed
like to us once Billboard found out oh
that's a black kid well this isn't
country so that prompted people to be
pissed and then you start digging into
the origins of it and saying wow so I
definitely hear what you're saying
because I felt the same way about [ __ ]
like Vans
ya know they're like we always talked
about they're taking out but then now
you didn't skateboard yeah you know yeah
but there's somebody he'd be like no
back in 1972 James
you never know but for this one is like
yeah I definitely I'm stand behind that
[ __ ] because it was all fun until we
found out he was black like it oh yeah
that's the part I didn't know about I
was like I was the only thing I said was
I was like why would you want that
music yeah but but that is one thing
that I want to caution people against
and not just black people because all
ethnicities have this this is our
culture get away from the [ __ ] but it
doesn't get highlighted unless you know
that's going on but my thing is if
you're gonna be the people that say
don't steal our culture don't then say
well two can play that game you know
they're that's that's always bugged me a
little bit it's like either you want
them to stay away or you want everything
to be inclusive but you can't have it
both ways you can say don't take my
culture and give me some of yours and
i'ma go back and find what's my thing
first is something like like a spice you
know we abandon the [ __ ] out of you know
yeah
that's why that word was such a weird
thing because when I use I don't know
another word for closer appropriation
like you know like how do you always
have to bring that up and say well you
you're putting a lot of weight onto it
and it's just a word that's used now
that I'm using it like for me I'm not
too hot on that word because I think
people use it to me you know me a buzz
word it's it's a [ __ ] buzz word so
like yeah like you you just have to
understand where people are coming from
when they use it and then you take it
for what it is after ya says because
people are like why do you keep using
that word it's like well give me another
word for it then yeah exactly
is it triggering ass word though I think
it's just ignorant people make things
much worse than they are because you can
say that to somebody and they'll take it
and run with it and now everything you
do that's slightly similar all you're
appropriating my culture you know I'm
saying like it's just yeah it gets weird
like the whole race ethnicity cultural
[ __ ] is like it's interesting but I'm
like damn when are we going to stop
doing this like did you see the the New
Zealand Burger King commercial mm-hmm
okay so they I do believe they
introduced like some Vietnamese burger
or some [ __ ] like yeah that Vietnamese
flavors or something and they made a
commercial with giant chopsticks people
trying to eat a bird
girl with giant chopsticks right and a
lot of Asians I'm really pissed about
that yeah and at first I'm like what the
[ __ ] are you thinking Burger King and
I'm still like that because Burger King
did some [ __ ] they had mary j blige
singing about fried chicken one time but
then i'm like what exactly is the issue
here yeah the big chopsticks the
chopsticks being used with a burger or
the fact that there's no Asian people or
is it because they had a Vietnamese
flavor and they used chopsticks like
nobody's saying what's actually wrong
with it and I'm not saying that there's
nothing wrong with it I just don't know
what's wrong with it yeah and that's
what happens a lot where's people just
met but nobody's really saying why
because if you made a video where you
were like okay I'm gonna do the
chopstick challenge where you try to eat
foods you wouldn't normally eat with a
chopstick with chopsticks that would be
funny and people would do it you know
azalea China eat a [ __ ] hot dog with
chopsticks yeah yeah why is it super
offensive in this context and I haven't
got that answer yet and not that I'm
saying it's not I don't know I'd like to
see further the video but I guess right
at the top of my head I think I guess
it's just more like it's hard to offend
me you know to be honest with you it's
really hot like that I know why it's
offensive but it's like it's such a
[ __ ] low-hanging fruit type of insult
yeah it goes right over my head yeah it
looks like that dumb and you just move
on you know so I people like when they
were using it um they were there was
definitely two white people there was a
dude who looked like he could be but I'm
not really sure
probably just it looks like white people
are making funny Asian people you know
like what is this thing it's just one of
those like old like racial jokes that's
part that's probably just it yeah that's
it something very simple you know just
it it's weird because like white people
are in this in this realm now what you
you just can't
oh yeah why it's it's finally tough for
y'all okay
do or say I'm sorry
welcome to the cloud your turn I guess
they're like whoa whoa
what did I do how come I have to go this
is unlike welcome what did I do
so that sympathy's not very bad yeah
that's not sad part like I understand
it's like they're like well I go through
stuff it's like we're not saying you did
it but I'm saying welcome to the club so
maybe you can understand a little bit
why sometimes when you know black dude
walks into place and they're like this
dude's stealing and now you have the
weights now you know what's funny my
parents don't uh we own a black piece of
plastic so every customer was black but
I remember I got so many when I'm
getting old and I had a mouthpiece on me
lady comes in and mind you this lady
with a [ __ ] crack it like not even
that's a joke she was graduating day
correct yeah she did crack so she's
coming up here just [ __ ] angry and
[ __ ] and she's trying to swipe [ __ ]
right I'm like you gotta leave right she
was why is it cuz I'm black I was like
[ __ ] everybody's black in here it's a
black beauty supplies what are you
talking about
babe I'm like that doesn't even work in
this yeah exactly
everybody's black does your black me
more like we need black people to come
in here is a black beauty supply store
you don't see my mom holding a little
black baby giving her kisses like what
are you talking about actually used to
piss me off and I'm like you are the
heart of this whole store we're in a
black neighborhood what are you saying
did you know that that's my design
what you mean and you touched on it um
with your film oh yeah yeah say the
title yes so I we both knew backstory on
that yeah um I dug a little deeper and I
think we talked about this before yeah
about the Korean owner who shot the
black girl
yeah so it turns out the beef was
basically by design so before that what
what I read up on uh I read all of this
stuff I don't claim to be an expert you
guys say [ __ ] like America didn't like
Asians yeah you know they didn't like
black people they had black people and
they had us all in impoverished areas on
purpose of course but then they needed
to turn it up a notch so they started
being really nice to Asians so nice and
giving them leg up here and there and
say hello yeah and we got some prime
real estate
you can opener this here and it there
and that there most of it was in the
black neighborhoods liquor stores any
type of [ __ ] doughnut shops whatever you
know I'm saying while neglecting to let
black people purchase anything in that
area mmm you can't there's no black
store owners and not because there's no
ability to be yeah they simply won't let
it you know we're not gonna sell to you
type [ __ ] right yeah but then they use
that to say see these Asians came from a
totally different country with nothing
and they picked themselves up by them
bush by their bootstraps why can't black
people do that see black people are lazy
black people are this black people are
that so it was just to pit us against
each other
and it [ __ ] worked because now you
have impoverished black people seeing
Outsiders in their community making
money and taking the money back to their
community and it's like you know what
the [ __ ] so there's already that beef
yeah with that part of the beef you got
black people deciding [ __ ] these people
stealing [ __ ] all the time so now that
any people like stupid [ __ ] and it was
just wow like set of a festive America
look what we did yeah this is amazing
work just like we planned it was crazy
because I actually mentioned you when we
were doing
the whole because we had we touched not
on that debt but we kind of touched on
this where I mentioned you when we were
doing the whole [ __ ] press tour and
stuff like that because of that's
conversation that we had and it was such
the way we kind of really touched upon
was you know we were looking at the
wrong people you know yeah you're
literally looking at the wrong people
because it was that concept where you
had these Asian immigrants they come in
and then there's this guy and at the
bank it's like well you want to open a
missed use guy to get a loan and then we
would get a loan yeah but then Asian
people didn't understand about this
cultural plight that black people had
yeah and so all they're taught is what
America teaches them about black people
yeah exactly
and so they're just like oh well how
come they're not getting along I got a
loan they don't know they can't get a
loan yeah and so all they know and they
don't speak the language they can't even
talk to any like black people in their
community so all they have are these
assumptions that I would say white
Americans taught them yeah you know so
they're just like oh well I
I made this business how come they
haven't done it later than this country
for so long yeah but there's just this
whole backstory that people didn't
understand so people are angry at the
wrong people and there's no empathy
there's there's no communication they
can't look at each other and say oh so
this is what happened they don't speak
English yeah black people already been
beat up for so long they're just bitter
at this point I mean how why wouldn't
you beat me exactly so it's just such a
weird situation and so what [ __ ] did was
to say like yo like same situation
different people yeah exactly exactly
and it's so hard to get most people to
see that there's two sides to that and
to look at who's actually doing people
don't want to know people across the
board I always say that this is
completely off topic but on topic I
always said that about servers and tips
mm-hmm and cuz you know that's a whole
big thing like if you can't afford to
kid didn't don't go out there like hey
don't be mad at the customer why is your
employer paying you enough to where you
don't need tips to survive yeah but
nobody looks that way if this is between
me and you buddy yeah I served you food
you give me extra money on top of what
you paid for the food and it's like no
you got a paycheck why isn't it enough
so that's just that's how they do the
higher-ups they they plant these seeds
and they just let that [ __ ] grow while
they watch
and they get away with it okay
interesting the hard part about that
tipping system is like what I say is
when people like I agree with you and
there's another side where it's like
well actually I do agree with you
because it's just the hot it's there's
no living wage you know so in this
country tip is a cultural thing so if
you come into this country and then you
don't tip and you wonder why it's kind
of like if I went to a country and I did
tip and I get it thrown it back in my
face yeah you know so it's that you kind
of have to roll with what the cultural
standard norm is and it's hard because
what you know because I own a couple of
businesses now people also don't want to
live up to that expectation of what
they're paid for yeah and that's the
part that annoys me it's like cool you
want to be a server I'll pay you $17 an
hour but you have to live up to that $17
and now you know because this is what is
expected out of you there's no random oh
I'm going on the snow trip oh can you
cover my shift here and there there's no
none of that
yeah you're getting paid good you can
take good so now you need to be able to
work your weight in gold yeah and people
don't also want that too so it's like
well what the [ __ ] you want and that's
how a lot of [ __ ] is it's going it's so
far gone that there's no immediate
solution because it's like brainwashing
people feel like certain jobs are just
bottom of the barrel I don't have to
take this [ __ ] serious regardless of
what they're making yeah it's a you
probably should if you want to keep
making this example yeah it's it's all
weird and the the higher-ups get to just
watch it because when the when the
minimum wage you know it's going up and
people didn't understand stuff well how
come these people are getting fired to
use like why can't you just pay us cuz
there's no [ __ ] money yeah exactly
that's the main reason why I don't have
employees in anything tip it's it's that
that has to be difficult is what to do
it you know like it has to be you can't
charge prices that are gonna allow you
to pay people what they really need and
you still grow yourself yep but you need
people say yeah it's a weird situation
cuz like for them I understand because I
was in that position you you know grew
up [ __ ] broke as [ __ ] I understand but
it's like I could either hire you know
four to five
full-time people they get paid this
great wage right yeah but these people
have but now you have to work full time
you're working 40 hours a week yeah
people aren't gonna want to work 40
hours a week on this job to get paid
that amount yeah
so it's like that's why there are the
part-time that's why you get the lower
wage you know so it's like do you you
you can't it goes back to you can't pick
and choose those battles you got to
stick to one which one are you gonna be
yeah everybody wants to have the cake
and eat it too and it's not like so even
in that situation like that thing was
better I always see hits all the time
when I was a kid was well you [ __ ]
aging people you guys over there only
you been eating good I'm like bro bro I
wish you knew that was the other part of
it's like we're gonna give you this loan
Asian man
but it's only enough to Ford something
in this community and if they don't buy
your [ __ ] yeah and that's what it was
like I grew up I was like no I'm
probably arguably like because I'm also
Asian put Asian people there too for me
anyone in my family would - almost like
too prideful to even take government
assistance because that's stupid Asian
pride so it's like what the [ __ ] you
know it's like we're just [ __ ] we're
just like scraping by every [ __ ] week
yeah and so you know but people don't
see that they just see that you own
something you own something it's like
you don't see me this [ __ ] t-shirt
I've been wearing for the [ __ ] board
and it is interesting that I try to
study people yeah and she's interesting
I saw this clip I forgot what it was on
but they use monkeys and he did this
thing they put two monkeys in cages next
to each other and they had a task it was
like handing the person a rock they put
a rock outside the cage they grab the
rock hand it's a person when they hand
him the rock they get a cucumber they
caught on quick if I gave the rock I get
a cucumber so they're doing that a
couple of times both monkeys and then
they swap one of the monkeys cucumbers
out for grapes so the other monkey can
see is like open cages type [ __ ] so this
monkey Grizz the rock gets a great this
monkey gives the rock gets a cucumber
and he's kind of looking at the cucumber
like all right maybe they just haven't
switched my bowl out yet yeah this is a
cucumber does it gay it's great he gets
a cucumber now he's like no [ __ ] he you
give him grapes now
I want my grape yeah when he was
perfectly fine with the cucumber when
everybody was getting cucumbers but now
he's getting pissed off like this monkey
is getting mad he's [ __ ] shaking the
cane and [ __ ] like yo no what the [ __ ]
is going on yeah I see this
[ __ ] grapes he's right in front
of me I'm still getting these plugins
and and that reminds me of people so
much that's how we are if you see
somebody getting better for doing the
exact same [ __ ] as you you get pissed
you get [ __ ] pissed and they they do
that strategically for you to see and
it's like they're that's crazy
this that's just how they playing with
people that's I gotta see that [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] hilarious yeah you know
what they found out they found out like
primates are slowly going into the Stone
Age right now the show so we're watching
like evolution before our eyes
and that's like it creeps me out yeah
they're speeding it up so how'd he put a
human brain into a monkey
what yeah and uh was it China Korea I
want to be yeah and everybody's kinda
like yo what the [ __ ] you don't have
you've not seen Planet of the Apes like
what is going on yeah [ __ ] all that
noise dude and I heard that there uh
they said that um they're starting to
develop religion yeah super monkeys and
robots that's what we all have to do it
I'm not having kids yeah they're like
we're making movies about [ __ ] not to do
like the only thing I want is a [ __ ]
car to drive me around that's it
I'm good well I want good public
transportation for LA you uh you get rid
of that car
I [ __ ] miss it a little bit god damn
that [ __ ] was expensive yeah it's
dangerous too I heard um even though Joe
was telling me to about public
transportation in LA like how it was
systematically set for it to [ __ ] up
anyway specifically for oil companies so
I can't remember the exact details but
essentially they they did something
where they made it so that public
transportation was not the viable choice
just so they could sell more cars and so
now because of that foundation we have
to
public transportation in a city with a
[ __ ] ton of [ __ ] people that mean it
yeah that's what I want like I want a
great public transportation I would use
that [ __ ] all the time yeah like in New
York yeah and now we're stuck in a place
where it's it's few and far between
there's like a train every like 20 30
minutes yeah and there's somebody
jacking off in a [ __ ] corner yeah
they put him to put the stops in like
the worst neighborhood
ever yeah cuz I was going to uh like
Pasadena to Little Tokyo and the first
car that I was in it was you know cause
a homeless dude but the man clearly
hasn't bathed in like seven years yeah
and everybody had to leave that that
that dali truck area because it was so
it smells so bad people couldn't breathe
yeah you know because even for me people
understand what I tell them it's like
well let's have a public transportation
where if you want to be in a premium
area you could pay for that premium yeah
but at least make the other stuff
affordable for everybody else yeah
because then the city could make money
but obviously it's not going to happen
it's ridiculous
dan we've been going for an hour that
was [ __ ] quick so what would what can
they find you um you catch me on
instagram Erika shucks YouTube
youtube.com slash
IB shucks check out the No Chaser
podcast yeah everywhere hilarious by the
way [ __ ] funny has a podcast thank
you sir and um goodie brand act huh you
guys I think you should drop in yes a
lot of new [ __ ] dropping right now we
just dropped this hat just wanted to do
a quick little hat release but we got a
bunch of other [ __ ] even before we
caught by the way clothing is [ __ ]
hard it is I love it though god dammit
it's so [ __ ] long I just want to make
dope [ __ ] I want people to wear it but
it's just it's not that simple you know
it's so [ __ ] hard yeah and it's the
one industry there's something that I
hate doing something that I'm not great
at and this is something that I have not
been able to crack yeah you know and
it's just like what what what am i doing
would you like for me to tell you now
our way through you know
because is the exact same thing we did
wrong God will talk about alright job
well we'll see you next time
check out Ricki shucks check out the No
Chaser pod cast
check out goodie brand they make dope
dope [ __ ] and yeah we'll see y'all next
time you check us on Spotify pod can
iTunes podcast give us that five star
rating and leaving the comments below
what you want to hear us talk about and
everything else so see y'all next time